So we continue to see absolute bottom feeding
garbage coming out of Fox News about the virus
and one primary source of that trash.
Really, that pond scum is the show Fox and
Friends.
Fox and Friends is hosted by Steve Doocy,
Ainsley Earhart and Brian KILMEADE.
Here's a clip in which Ainsley Earhart talks
about how it's just so frustrating.
She's staying outside the city, New York City.
She has an apartment in the city.
How privilege bills are piling up.
She can't get her nails done.
She can't return the clothes she bought that
have a 30 day return policy.
Can't we do something about all this?
But it's interesting to know we're talking
about this.
And every day we're talking about different
topics because we're moving in hopefully the
direction of getting to where China is now
or South Korea is now.
I'm just getting some improvement.
Let let me just stop there for one second.
Even the language of hopefully we're now going
in the direction of China and South Korea
is so bogus.
China shut everything down for weeks and weeks.
South Korea tested extensively.
Did contact tracing, coordinated isolation
and quarantine for weeks before they turned
the numbers around.
Half of our states haven't done a thing yet.
Half of our states haven't started fighting
coronavirus.
And it's part of the propaganda that Donald
Trump started with on Sunday.
Remember Sunday night Trump started with we
don't want the cure to be worse than the disease.
Monday, Trump started with people want to
get back to work.
Tuesday, Trump said, I'd love people back
to work by Easter Tuesday night.
Or maybe it was Wednesday, Trump said.
I want the churches packed on Easter.
They're pretending like they're winning this
and they're not.
And Ainsley Eckhart is doing it.
But the numbers aren't improving.
It's just it's simply a fantasy world.
It took two days to go from 400000 to 500000
cases globaly.
In the U.S., cases are increasing more rapidly
than in any other country.
And Ainsley Earhart is participating in this
propaganda of, you know, now that it looks
like things are sort of hopefully starting
to improve.
They're not.
We haven't.
It's dangerous.
But let's continue with the clip.
But I was thinking, you know, we all live
in the city.
Can't go back to the say you can.
But I don't want to because I don't want to
be around the area that's infected the most.
But I'm thinking like all the bills that are
stacking up at my apartment and we've got
to think about that kind of thing.
If you bought clothing before all this happened,
if you want to return it, our store is going
to get a wave that 30 day period where you
can get your money back if you need to return
something.
These are all the things people are staying
home.
Women don't think about this, guys.
But, you know, this is not a priority.
But women have to get their hair done.
I saw someone tweet out.
You're going to see what color our real hair
is because our roots are going to grow in
women.
All my friends are saying, you know, this
is not a priority.
People are dying.
And I realize that, but they can't get their
nails done.
You know, businesses are closed everywhere.
It's just we're in priority mode right now.
It's pharmacy's and it is grocery stores that
doesn't really the only places people are
going now.
STF She has stuff.
She wants to return to stores guys.
She can't get her dye job done.
She can't get her nails done.
How is this news?
What is this?
She has to keep inserting the disclaimer.
You'll notice people are dying.
I get it.
People are dying.
But we can't get our nails done.
I can't return my blouse to H&M or wherever
she shops.
It's a microcosm of Trumpism.
People are dying and that's bad.
But I can't get my nails done or return my
clothes to the store.
By the way, I don't know much about this.
Can't you file and polish your own nails?
Like, isn't that still something that women
are able to do or whoever is wants to file
and paint their nails like that?
Is that that much of a thing?
People can't paint their own nails now, or
am I stupid for thinking that?
Imagine when we get past this whenever it
is magin our grandchildren saying Grandma.
Is it true that you had to go months without
a professional manicure and you weren't able
to exchange some pants because of the pandemic?
Did that was.
Did that really happen, grandma?
Now, it is true that whoever does those blonde
dye jobs at Fox News, they may actually be
suffering hugely.
I was checking out a picture of all the people
at Fox News past and present who are relying
on those blonde dye jobs to avoid showing
the dark roots that Ainslee refers to.
There are certainly a lot that's going to
impact some businesses.
And of course, that's not good.
But this is just continued gaslighting and
propaganda from Fox News.
Day after day after day, we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today in which I am not
at all involved.
Fridays are producer Pat Bonus shows producer
Pat is now quarantined.
Sort of just self-isolation.
I call it quarantine.
It's not really that at his home studio.
He's filming out of his gym where you will
see if you haven't watched any of his bonus
show appearances.
He has a punching bag, multiple mirrors, various
tapestries and musical instruments, a ping
pong table.
That's where Pat has set up his home studio
and where he's doing the editing.
So Pat's got the bonus show today.
I will be back on Monday, hopefully assuming
nobody catches the virus or something else.
Something worse.
Better, who knows?
I look forward to seeing you on Monday.
Grab a membership, watch the bonus show.
Join Packman dot com or Patriarca slash David
Pakman.